hi my name is Alex Fedak I'm an offering
manager at IBM and today I'm gonna talk
to you about what is a GPU so I get some
pretty basic questions on GPUs and
that's what I'm gonna go over today
first question is what is a GPU what is
the difference between a GPU and a CPU
so I'm gonna represent those here and
then lastly why use a GPU and isn't even
important to use a GPU on cloud so let's
start first with what is a GPU GPU
stands for a graphic processing unit but
oftentimes people are more familiar with
CPUs so CPUs are actually made up of
just a few course you can think of these
cores as the power the ability of a CPU
to do certain calculations or
computations on the other hand though
GPUs are made up of hundreds of course
but what difference does it make so the
thing with a CPU is that when it does a
computation it does so in a serial form
so it does one computation at a time but
with a GPU it does it in parallel so the
importance of these two differences is
that with a GPU you're able to do
computations all at once and very
intense computations at that so often
times when you have app codes a lot of
it's going to be going to the CPU but
then every now and then you're going to
have an application that's going to
require quite a bit of compute intensive
support that the CPU just can't do so
it's going to be offloaded to the GPU so
you can think of a GPU as that extra
muscle or that extra brain power that
the CPU just can't do on its own so
there are two main providers of GPUs in
industry nvidia and AMD both providers
manufacture GPUs that are optimized for
certain use cases so let's jump into
that because big question I get is why
do I even need a GPU in what industries
and in what use cases so the first we'll
talk about is BDI media i stands for
virtual desktop infrastructure
so GPUs are created to support high
intensive graphic applications so for
think about if you are a construction
worker right and you're out in the field
and you need to access a very high
graphic intensive 3d CAD program so
rather than having the server right next
to your right in the field with you you
can have a server that's in a country
away in a cloud datacenter and be able
to view that 3d graphic as if that
server was right with you
and that's going to be supported by the
GPU because the GPU supports graphic
intensive applications another example
of this would be movie animation or
rendering so in fact GPUs actually first
got their name mainly with the gaming
industry oftentimes they were referred
to as gaming processing units because of
this ability to provide end-users with
low latency graphics but gaming is no
longer the focus in industry anymore
it's big piece of it but now financial
services life sciences and even
healthcare are starting to get into it
with artificial intelligence so
artificial intelligence has two big
pieces to it there's machine learning
and there's deep learning so now there
are also GPUs that are optimized and
created specifically for those
applications so there are some that are
created for inferencing for machine
learning purposes and there are some
that are created to help data scientists
create and train neural networks in
other words they're trying to create
these algorithms that can think like a
human brain that's something that a CPU
can simply not do on its own and
requires GPU capabilities and then
lastly let's talk about HPC HPC is a
buzzword that's been going around it
stands for high-performance computing
while a GPU is not absolutely necessary
for HPC it's an important part of it so
high-performance computing is the
company's ability to spread out their
compute intensive workloads amongst
multiple compute nodes or in the case of
cloud servers oftentimes though these
applications are very compute intensive
it could include rendering it could
include AI and that's where a GPU comes
and you can add a GPU to these servers
that are spread out amongst an HPC
application and utilize those in that
manner so this is a nice little segue
into why should we use GPUs on cloud if
HPC is such a big piece of that what
else is important about cloud so the
first part of that is you get high
performance you need cloud for that the
GPUs are great but not on their own so
back in the day and even still today
there are companies that use a lot of on
Prem infrastructure and they utilize
that infrastructure for any of their
compute intensive applications however
especially in the case of GPUs the
technology is ever changing in fact
there's typically a new GPU coming out
almost every single year so it's
actually very expensive and nearly
impractical for companies to keep up
with the latest technology at this point
so cloud providers actually have the
ability to continually update their
technology and provide GPUs to these
companies to utilize them when they need
them so on a more granular basis though
cloud technology can often be broken
down from an infrastructure perspective
between bare metal and virtual servers
so let's talk about the differences
there are advantages of using a GPU on
both types of infrastructure if you
utilize a GPU on a bare metal
infrastructure the companies oftentimes
have access to the entire server itself
and they can customize the configuration
so this is great for companies that are
going to be really utilizing that server
and that GPU intense application on a
pretty consistent basis but for
companies that need a GPU maybe just on
a burst workload scenario the virtual
server option might be even better and
the nice thing about virtual is that
there are often different pricing models
as well including hourly and the cool
thing about cloud is that you only pay
for what you use so if a company is
using on-prem technology or
infrastructure but they're not utilizing
it at the time that technology is
depreciating
and it's essentially a waste of money
for that company so it just makes a lot
more sense from a cost perspective and
then because the GPU is so great at
performance it just makes sense from a
performance perspective as well so
companies are able to focus way more on
output than they are on keeping up with
the latest technology so in summary what
we covered is what is a GPU graphic
processing unit what the difference is
between a GPU and a CPU the use cases
for GPUs being in VDI AI and HPC and why
is it even important for GPUs to be used
on cloud thank you guys for joining me
here today to learn about what is a GPU
if you'd like to learn more about GPUs
click on the links below and we're
always checking the comments so feel
free to throw one in there for us and be
sure to subscribe for future videos